i was at the top of the mountain
and now i'm back at the base
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
we feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by kenan thompson
from his roots at nickelodeon to
becoming the longest tenured cast member
in saturday night live history he's been
making us laugh for over 25
years he also stars in a new comedy
series from nbc it's called keenan
tuesdays 8 30 7
30 central keenan thompson welcome to
the show man
thank you for having me i'm a big fan i
have literally
seen all of them down to the game show
so
wow i'm gonna hold up i'm flattered uh
if you don't mind me asking do you have
like a favorite episode
i think i'm gonna flip into my gordon
ramsay impression when it starts to get
pretty hot
that was an incredible episode i also
made my eggs like that
thanks to that episode so that was
incredible that was incredible
pete was great i'm surprised he got
through it you know what i mean because
he does have like intestinal issues
they're all pretty solid man like once
that like
first kick kicks in and you do that
effect where you know they're starting
to feel
feel some heat you know what i mean i
can't wait till it happens to me so it
it's just really funny and like really
smart and it's awesome i don't
understand how your stomach is still
intact because you go through it all
like fearlessly all the way down
[Music]
we're going with the classic let's go
salud
salud
okay so we're already starting off in a
hot spot
so this is going to be definitely
interesting
this is a good wing wing it so let's
begin with this new chapter in your
career going from as you put it a piece
of the puzzle at
snl to now shouldering a major network
primetime tv show that you not only star
in but also one that bears your name
one of the parts of the show's premise
that i found amusing was that you played
the host of atlanta's number two morning
show
yeah we're we're always there for jokes
even in the description you know
like that's what i think you have to do
especially
coming on the heels of a 30 rock or
parks and rec or office type of a
culture you know like everything is very
progressive
throwing out millions of jokes every 10
seconds coming in with a comedy show
in that kind of culture yeah we got to
come with jokes all the time so
that that's where that is basically like
we could easily be like yeah i'm the
best
but where's the joke or not
[Music]
okay that's on the sweeter side that's a
nice little sweet y'all see this is how
you get people hooked in right
oh it's all good i can just sauce up all
these wings
that's when watching the back catalog is
is an advantage in this game you know
you can see the tricks coming
yeah man people all happy in the
beginning like yeah don't talk about my
career
i understand that you're pretty
comfortable on ice skates what do you
remember about the mechanics of
choreographing hockey scenes and the
mighty ducks and then who taught you how
to knuckle puck
well the knuckle puck is you know our
hockey coach was this guy named jack
white and he
used to host like the kids junior
olympic hockey team or something and his
daughter was an incredible hockey player
as well
she was incredibly good and also very
encouraging she was just always like
yeah you know dig in learn how to use
your edges and blah blah
very supportive environment her father
on the other hand
used to give me [ __ ] constantly like
come on russ used to call me by my
character name come on i was like you
know i'm a person i'm not just
my character but he had us locked in and
like would just break us
of wanting to quit or wanting to be like
oh we can just use our stunt doubles he
was like no you guys are going to be a
real team
so we just played all day it was great
one of the biggest strengths of
all that were the musical guests which
helped to introduce
craig mack the lox aaliyah to fourth
graders
all over the country looking back do you
have an all-time favorite musical
performance from that show
all time i mean tlc set the bar pretty
high you know
like we were obsessed with them and then
they came and they were so cool
they did the theme song and then they
came and performed in the first season
and then we had people like
usher at a young age you know and coolio
came through and that was an interesting
week because
coolio stuck up the studio and that was
the first time like us kids were kind of
exposed to the smell of that going on in
the hallway yeah all right mark
let's go to barbados toss and toss toast
house
flippy toast interesting
that's good
starting to kick that spice huh mm-hmm
all right so you've been a staple on
saturday night live for 18 seasons so
i'm sure that
in the hundreds of episodes that you've
done in studio 88 you've seen it all
i know that creating that show it's a
collaborative process but it's also
extremely competitive
looking back was there an og cast member
who you recognize with
helping you to break through all that
yeah i mean
tracy was like the first one like he
wasn't even in the cast anymore but for
some reason he was still around that
first week
like writer's night just holding court
in the middle of the conference room
sitting there telling jokes and blah
blah and then he took me and finesse to
lunch
at tgi fridays and it was a half a
blocks
walk but we walked two blocks away to
get his car out of the garage
and then drive around the corner to tgi
fridays
and he was like the first person to be
like yo listen to me this is how you do
it blah blah blah
engage these writers you know what i'm
saying go to the you know the darker
ones or whatever and see what you can
learn from them and
everybody else on down i kind of learned
by watching basically because they were
just performing at such a high
level it seemed like they were in
another atmosphere stratosphere or some
[ __ ] like that
you know when you think back on all the
sketches that maybe made it to the table
read but got
cut before they went to the live show is
there one that you regret never got to
see the light of day
there i mean i was hung up on this one
that was uh
active jack the idea was bruno mars was
like
one of those 70s workout kind of tv show
kind of guys named active jack like come
on kids and he was did these songs to
get the kids to work out
and stuff and it was like the 40th year
anniversary so
like cut to is me like old and out of
shape
redoing the song and stuff like that it
was really funny but
when we did it with bruno mars it was
pretty well received and then
it just didn't make it to the show and i
was kind of crushed
kevin hart ended up being able to do it
years later
so it lives you know what i'm saying
again kind of spicy bro it's getting
kind of spicy so this is definitely
interesting let's just keep it pushing
though you know might as well
right we here right that's the devil's
blend huh
yeah that tastes like satan
that's taking that yeah that's the devil
[Music]
so from growing up on outcast in atlanta
to just recently actually dropping your
debut verse as tiny diamond and trolls
world tour it seems like you've long had
a love affair with hip-hop and you've
played rick ross you've played ice cube
you've played suge knight
is there a key to doing a hip-hop
impression knowing that rappers are so
lazily lampooned elsewhere in pop
culture
i mean i think it depends on the
individual like ice cube has a very
clear tone to the way he talks you know
what i'm saying like it's a very
clear tone doc and he's always frowned
and then ross of course big bows you
know all that like when i'm gone
excuse me i caught a little yeah best
favorite impression i ever did was rick
ross
suge knight i think you got a no should
to like
listen to him you know what i'm saying
he said he's a deep individual his his
voice is a little higher than you might
assume just because he's so big
that's kind of the way he talks he talks
like with a real menace it's gonna be
coming at the end of his sentence
i'm proud of myself we got into the
halfway mark man this is what's up
it shake it what's happening
see that's what it starts to do it
starts to throw out hot
just crazy spikes in places and make you
react to things
well that ain't necessary you don't need
all that
you don't need all that but okay
okay all right kingdom we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context
so i'll show you the picture you just
tell us the bigger story
here you are backstage with the legend
alex trebek at the nhl awards last year
was he aware of black jeopardy
that was the first thing he mentioned he
actually said
god bless you for figuring out a way to
do a jeopardy behind
the legendary will feral jeopardy you
know it seems like anything will fair
was kind of like
holy grail-ish off-limits-ish you know
my writing buddy brian tucker and
michael che are two brilliant dudes when
they figured out a take on it that was
just chock full of too many jokes to
ignore basically so
he was patting me on the back about that
but i was patting him on the back for
probably being one of the smartest
people in the
world because it seems like he knows the
answer to all those jeopardy questions
he has a way of responding to each
question like
no of course like it's this and then the
other because i read this book or i've
known about this
historic town in rome or you know i'm
saying he was incredible
and i was asking him about his health
and he was saying he was feeling better
and
fighting through it and stuff like that
so it was quick but
very very positive
[Music]
it's about to get real all right
we're doing it the same way each time
basically is what you're saying
yeah big drip big drip well you know
that's how we do out here player big
drip
mouth on fire two seconds later
all right cool
a little bit of a time delay here
should be about a three two one feel
that
but it's still pretty good i'm not doing
it
you're doing great keenan you're doing
great i'm not doing too bad
so there are countless quotes about you
from lorne michaels and past castmates
that basically boil down to you being
an ultimate teammate reliable somebody
who pumps oxygen
into sketches rather than sucking the
air out of the room
is that something that came to you
naturally or early on in your career was
there ever a time where you were a
little more
me me me about things no i'm a taurus
man
i'm mellow you know what i'm saying and
i'm a little you and me you and me
when's your birthday
april 26th oh nice april um i'm may 10th
so yeah you know we're strong we're
strong very
hard-minded individuals probably um
but i never want people to like turn all
the attention on me i'm big on the
mindset of ensembleness
so yeah i mean i'm i'm definitely trying
to see it's starting to burn my lip a
little bit now
i'm starting to feel that that's a
little that's a little burn on that
there
it's happening so you know um
yeah i i love to hear that you know
people feel like i i inject positivity
instead of negativity like i
i'd much rather be happy than sad you
know it just feels like natural logic to
me
right honey badger don't do me dirty now
we already suffered through the super
bowl with you
i'm smelling it and i'm i'm i'm hesitant
but i'm gonna go for it
okay that's sweet relief
until until it starts happening
right now it's like a volcano
slow eruption i like that though
hell yeah i think you're a spice guy i
think you're a spice man
am i a spice man like if i could give
her a spice in my
other three i earned my spice degree
yeah yeah we send you a commemorative
plate that also rhymed by the way
get through the other three earned that
spice degree oh
snap coming off the dome so i've read
that you're a prolific stock trader and
pride yourself on being able to read the
wall street ticker
a recent snl cold open spoofed that
whole wall street
bets phenomenon with pete davidson
playing the majority shareholder of
gamestop
what's your take on this recent
phenomenon of meme stocks and then all
that's going on with social media and
stock trading
yeah i mean that whole movement is
incredible um
just the fact that they tried to show
that the system is rigged and then the
system showed them that it is rigged you
know what i'm saying like
it's like yo we have big money in place
so yeah you can play those games for a
day but then we're going to show you the
next day that all of that is about to
fall back
whoever was able to get in and out that
same day man
god kudos to you if you saw that coming
and you were inside enough to know that
that was happening
i'm not that far inside i can only watch
and hope
and pray basically i'm definitely just
gambling with it
being in the entertainment industry for
decades means that you've had no
shortage of people telling
you what to do with your money looking
back what do you think is the worst
piece of financial advice you ever
received
uh giving somebody power of attorney
never give anyone the power of attorney
of anything
yeah that was an early lesson for me for
sure you're able to make your own
decisions
and be able to watch your money you
definitely should do it with somebody
like i always had mentors and stuff like
that
but i learned better by being involved
you know i didn't
learn anything about someone just
handling stuff for me
honey all right she's got to come back
for this one
okay we're going for the bomb wow that
choke me up this is the bomb
how much are we pouring historic moment
how much we pour in just the traditional
yeah that's that's football that's
plenty he says all right cool
that's a lot that's a lot that's a lot
man we're going crazy in here
i'm along for the ride i'm along for the
ride i smell it it smells like a problem
it does smell like a problem cheers
cheers again
yeah i see why you would say that that
would be a problem
[Music]
i was just trying to protect you from
yourself nah it's not even about flavor
anymore it's just about getting hot yeah
so that that's hot
i'm gonna need water for this one
starting to cough me up a little bit
i hear the live studio audience right
yeah was supposed to just continue with
that huh
wild man yeah that's hot bro
any more questions yeah yeah
so the nature of sketch shows seems so
burn the midnight oil
cram for a final exam sort of situation
what is the food situation like in the
writer's room like is it just pizza and
energy drinks or is there more to
sustain it
yeah man it's like um mcdonald's and
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] hot yo i'm telling you
we gotta slow this down yeah it's like
uh late night snacks or
we'll get like a full meal but yeah that
one is crazy though
you're sweating too you and me both you
mean
up from there is what you're saying
it goes up from there i don't know about
that on your podcast you already know
you talk about
everything including food how has this
pandemic
renewed or changed your love of cuisine
in unique and interesting ways
um like you used to not be able to get
delivery from like your favorite
high-end spots you know what i'm saying
so now it's like
they put together whole meal packages
for the family and you know
alcoholic packages or whatever if you
want to have like a full dining
experience
mix cocktails blah blah blah but
even though the food is really good you
want to go out you want to like be
social
so still a little depressing sometimes
that [ __ ] was hot bro
right
it's calming down but it calms down and
flares back up what's that about
[Music]
i don't know why they call it the bomb
you know like we're sweating
mouth burn
[Music]
all right so this next one is the eye of
the scorpion
i had a scorpion all right cool
[Music]
you work for it did you learn
that that last one is just an explosion
so it's better to like do it so people
can actually get through it
so we've kept it in in this spot since
like season two
but this has just stood the test of time
because it never
bricks on a reaction never i'm not even
spiced
anymore i feel like that one broke down
at the bottom finally so i'm coming down
off of that i'm just like terrified of
this one because i've seen what it does
to people
well you know what keenan i know that
you're a thrill seeker i know that you
are because you have an obsession with
roller coasters that goes
all the way back to being a kid and
working on this nickelodeon lot where a
lot of the shows were
shot at universal studios in florida
yeah
did being on that network give you carte
blanche in the amusement parks or did
you have to wait in line like everyone
else
back in the day i think it was just the
original universal challenge there was
like terminator 2
or something was like the main
attractions like 3d and
halloween horror nights i think was like
starting or like still in his first like
10 year phase or whatever so we used to
sneak through the back door
during lunch time and like ride a bunch
of rides and then come back
when halloween horror nights would come
we would like take a group of friends
and sneak through the back door once
again and then we just like have
so much halloween fun like for free uh
and then they started locking the door
because i think they were watching the
cameras
but you know we're kids you got to try
it like until you get caught basically
like that's what kids do push boundaries
i am not afraid we're gonna rub it in
rub it in so that everybody is
deliciously spicy
cheers my friend this has been an
absolute pleasure man
cheers keenan thank you so much
here we go another one not for flavor so
i'm expecting the explosion
it's coming
here comes
here it comes
oh yeah that's good
yeah that's a smoker all right i'm gonna
go like
whoa going back in i have one more wing
so that's good i mean i feel like after
that the bomb
i earned my stripes homie keenan
thompson
card carrying spiceman spiceman
i have many leather bound books
[Laughter]
okay keenan thompson our spicy wing
experience is coming to an
end but before we roll credits i want to
spotlight one of the many
brilliant sides of keenan thompson and
that is when it comes to the art of the
impression
in your nearly two decades on snl you've
broken records for the number of
impressions performed so if you'll humor
me
i want to channel some of those
legendary caricatures while your brain
and mouth boil in scovilles
what up what up i'm photo with you
because i want to make a good post about
this later this has been a real
experience
it's explosive steve harvey which do you
prefer
drums or flats uh
honestly the flats is good for me you
know i like to chop a good drumstick
every now and again but i love getting
in between them blacksmithing
david ortiz with sauce in the lineup was
your favorite
i enjoyed the barbecue style because it
reminds me of the islands it's a very
sweet
and very spicy but the bomb man
that one is the truth man the bomb is
the truth
for big papi we eat a big lunch
and finally how would deandre cole react
to eating a wing
covered in the bomb spicy as hell
[Music]
burning up my mouth now
oh [ __ ] i'm sweating now baby
the spicy baby and i guess the same
whoa my mouth is burning what an
amazing run through the hot ones
gauntlet an
absolute treat keenan thompson and now
there is nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you
this camera that camera probably just
the camera you're looking at let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
thank you very much i mean you covered
it all man we podcasting out here the
show is coming out uh
february 16th and then it will be on on
tuesdays at 8 30 i guess
as that goes along sml still rolling
never going to stop you know what i'm
saying
and i'm always trying to perform or
create ways for others to perform so
that's what i would be up to
great job keenan great job i thought i
was gonna flip into my gordon ramsay man
i don't know why he was whining so hard
all right here we go [ __ ] on the heat
off the heat
put it on the heat now take it off the
heat oh man
brilliant that was a brilliant episode
spicy as hell
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
episode if you enjoyed it
maybe like it maybe you maybe throw us a
subscribe even if you're feeling
generous
and as long as you keep watching [ __ ] it
i'll keep eating